bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de parlement hebdo avec à mes côtés
katia gilbert bonjourbonjour nickel et
au sommaire de ce numéro on reviendra
sur les propositions de françois
hollande qui est venu à l'assemblée
nationale faire des propositions sur les
institutions et le temps fort au sénat
mais quel le projet de loi égalité
citoyenneté réécrit de fond en compte
par la droite sénatoriale loi fourre
tout où dix ses détracteurs et puis
emmanuel macron poursuit son chemin
l'ancien ministre de l'économie aviv et
ses concurrents de droite mais aussi de
gauche et on va faire le film de la
semaine avec luc carvounas bonjour c'est
notre invité sénateur-maire socialiste
d'alfortville dans le val de marne vous
rédigez notamment les cahiers de la
présidentielle au ps peut-être future
base de programmes on en parlera allez
on va commencer par ce temps forts à
l'assemblée nationale la présence de
françois hollande
alors il n'était pas dans l'hémicycle
mais il est venu conclure un colloque
sur la démocratie sur les institutions
on va d'ailleurs écouter un premier
extrait c'était sur la fabrique de la
loi je propose donc que nous puissions
entièrement revoir la procédure
législative savoir le prendre le temps
nécessaire pour aborder les grandes
questions de sécurité de sociétés et
peut-être même de sécurité les lois
bioéthiques les libertés pouvoir se
limiter en revanche à une seule lecture
dans chaque assemblée
pour les textes où l'urgence est
prononcée faire que les amendements
puisse être adoptée en commission est
réduit au minimum en séance et je suis
même pour qu'il y ait une procédure
expresse qu'ils soient fixées au
parlement c'est à dire une délai un
délai limite comme il en existe pour les
lois de finances
luc carvounas été le grand soir le big
bang la révolution des institutions
selon vous non je n'ai pas vécu comme
cela je crois pas déjà remettre le
contexte ces deux journées
sont le fruit de travaux que nous avons
mené avec claude bartolone et michel
winock nous étions une petite trentaine
de membres à cette commission dont je
faisais partie et qui ont cette
commission a formulé des propositions
alors partira de la position où là le
rapport est ce qu'il en reste nous avons
à discuter un petit peu entre les
membres à la fin du discours du
président ce qui est un discours
important parce que quand on souligne ce
qu'est la vème république ce qu'elle
porte comme valeur et comment elle peut
faire fonctionner république n'y a pas
de sujet après c'est vrai qu'on doit
quand même se poser cette question
septennat ou pas septennat le présent à
l'entraînement oui le président de
république et d vous dis lectra moi je
pense que le quinquennat avec
l'inversion du calendrier affaibli
totalement de pouvoirs du parlement
voilà donc d'un côté vous avez le
pouvoir du parlement qui totalement
affaibli je parle en tous les cas de
l'assemblée nationale parce que dans au
sénat il ya l'adn que leur soit dans la
majorité ou l'opposition du pouvoir
avoir une expression qui est assez
propre à l'assemblée pardon mais quand
on est député élu de six semaines après
l'élection d'un président la république
que vous dites oh ensuite on vous dit tu
tiens ta légitimité du président donc tu
te tais et si tu ne t'es pas tu deviens
un frondeur
c'est pour cela que moi je n'aimais pas
cette expression des frondeurs et bien à
d'un côté on a la qualité de
l'inscription dans le temps avec le
septennat
pour le président de ne pas être en
campagne permanente parce qu'il ya la
campagne présidentielle maintenant on a
bien compris qui aura aussi
systématiquement une campagne des
primaires où ça raccourci le temps de
l'action du privilège
les propositions de françois hollande
hier c'étaient des propositions un peu
de campagne quand même c'était des
propositions qui s'inscrivent toutes les
manières dont la continuité de ce que
nous avons porté vos versements kenna
mais on ne peut pas dire ça comme ça
parce que encore une fois on parle de
nos institutions
celui qui en est le garant
dans ces institutions c'est le président
de la république donc il a rappelé des
fondamentaux c'est important notamment
qu'on n'a pas imaginé dans cette période
pré électorale que l'on puisse être
amené à passer une sixième république
moi je me rappelle de mon amie cécile
duflot à la conclusion des travaux elle
même vous a dit devant tout le monde
devant michelle line up devant claude
bartolone
je suis convaincu nous n'avons plus
besoin de 6ème république
et maintenant je constate pascal et
quand ils traitent ou primaire qu'elle
revient sur son idée
lannoy mais voyez que penser 12 mois
travaux nous avons beaucoup auditionné
beaucoup échangé puis je crois que j'ai
des propositions pertinentes et d'autres
points et notamment françois hollande
qui souhaite limiter le cumul des
mandats écoutez il faut maintenant
inventer le parlement du non cumul
ce qui revient à donner davantage de
moyens de aux parlementaires qui doivent
être essentiellement dédié à cette
mission pour préparer délibéré et
contrôler le pouvoir exécutif
après le non cumul des mandats je suis
favorable au non-cumul dans le temps à
trois mandats successifs pour les
parlementaire et d'exécutif et les
exécutifs locaux
il faut inventer le parlement du non
cumul est ce que cette forme est là pour
vous un sens c'est nous qui avons
inventé l'expression avec claude
bartolone dans les travaux que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure
moi je souris toujours quand on nous
fait des propositions de non cumul des
mandats dans ma tombe donc dans le temps
venant du président de la république qui
s'est inscrite à inscrire ce sa carrière
sur le cumul des mandats d'ailleurs je
me souviens que son premier discours
d'investiture
les premières minutes j'invite celles et
ceux qui ont envie de revoir la vidéo
il nous dit si je suis là devant vous il
parlait aux primaires qu'il l'avait
désigné à la primaire en 2011 c'est
parce que j'ai été maire c'est parce que
j'étais président du département c'est
parce que c'est hypocrite comme forme
n'est pas hypocrite c'est que je voulais
revenir dessus d'ailleurs j'entends
mais on peut en parler j'entends qu'ils
forment se modernise et nous les élus
j'ai pas de sujet mais j'aimerais bien
avant qu'on continue à faire plus plus
plus mieux mieux mieux qu'on pose quand
même le problème du statut de l'élu qui
est le vrai problème qui n'a pas été
posée et vous le problème de la
représentativité demain dans nos
hémicycle c'est un problème lié au fait
que nous n'avons pas de statut d'élu moi
je suis maire j'ai un conseiller
municipal qui est ouvrier vous croyez
malgré le fait que je fais la lettre à
son chef d'entreprise qui lui demande de
le libérer pour une commission
municipale vous croyez que chef
d'entreprise de lieberman
vous avez fait votre choix pour 2017
écoutez moi je suis maire d'alfortville
sénateurs j'ai annoncé que je ne me
représenterai pas au sénat après nous
allons avoir des débats j'ai vu que le
conseil national du parti à désigner les
circonscriptions pour les femmes et les
circonscriptions geler la
circonscription la 9e duval demain dans
laquelle alfortville et big three sont
n'a pas été est une circonscription
ouvert tout est ouvert vous ferez quoi
par exemple débat déjà gêné battrai avec
les militants des sections des deux
sections et après on verra
moi je joue collectif c'est pas mon
ambition personnelle et plus beaux bande
à moi qui suis fils d'ouvrier qui est
née alfortville qui a vécu et qui
travaille alfortville et quitte à un
fils de banlieue le beau mandat c'est le
mandat de maire le carbonate êtes vous
candidat à l'élection législative comme
on prête ces rumeurs pouvez vous nous
dire oui aujourd'hui je ne sais pas je
ans j'en discuterai déjà avec eux le
député sortant vous savez avant d'être
candidat soi même moi j'ai une notion à
la loyauté qu'un très important
contrairement à monsieur macron et je
n'oublie pas correct parce que je suis
devenu maire d'alfortville c'est parce
que avant moi il y avait un homme qui
s'appelle rené rouquet qui m'a fait
grandir en politique et qui aujourd'hui
le député du val-de-marne vous les faits
la porte ouverte si rené rouquet et
candidat à sa succession il aura tout
mon soutien c'est rené rouquet n'est pas
candidat alors il y aura une discussion
avec les militants s'appelle la
démocratie donc savoir qui est le
meilleur candidat
alors le cave on a cette semaine a fait
un gros plan sur le projet de loi
égalité citoyenneté qui étaient débattus
dans votre chambre c'est là
le texte voulu par manuel valls a été
largement amendé notamment le volet
logement et mixité sociale revue de
détail des positions de la droite très
dure sur ce texte avec tom tran huy
c'est un texte censé renforcer la
république et lutter contre l'apartheid
territorial sociale et ethnique dénoncé
par manuel valls
au lendemain des attentats de charlie en
janvier 2015 une formule choc
une ambition immense et à l'arrivée un
texte fourre tout articulé en trois
volets
l'engagement citoyen des jeunes le
logement social et enfin la lutte contre
le racisme et les discriminations
le projet de loi égalité citoyenneté que
nous avons l'honneur de vous présenter
avec emmanuelle cosse est un texte de
cohésion un texte pour faire bloc
un texte pour vivre en société tous
ensemble à tout âge de tout lieu de
toutes origines de toutes conditions
sociales
mais pour faire bloc le texte fait le
grand écart pêle mêle les mesures
portent sur la réserve citoyenne
le service civique les quotas de hlm le
burqini mais aussi plus étonnant les
gens du voyage ou encore le droit de la
presse hors sujet et irréaliste pour la
droite sénatoriale
il a dérivé pour devenir un texte obèses
et hétéroclite un cabinet de curiosités
une sorte de bon coin législatif en
commission la majorité sénatoriale a
sérieusement détricoter le texte les 25
% de logements sociaux destinés aux plus
modestes dans les quartiers non
prioritaires supprimés au nom des
spécificités des territoires
même sort pour le service civique
obligatoire pour toute une tranche d'âge
le délit d' entrave numérique ali vg
rejeter enfin car il recevable
tandis que la liberté de la presse est
sérieusement menacé par des ajouts de la
chambre haute
recentrage explique la droite recule
selon la gauche
l'actuelle majorité du sénat a enlevé
des mesures phare
et c'est bien embêtant donc j'espère que
les débats permet de revenir au texte
qui était celui du gouvernement celui de
l'assemblée nationale les débats
s'annoncent donc long deux semaines est
tendue le sénat devrait largement
remanié le texte au grand dam du
gouvernement fin des hostilités le 18
octobre
alors le texte a été largement amendé on
l'a vu par la droite sénatoriale sacré
c'est la droite dure c'est l'expression
d'une droite dure que vous voyez là
l'investigation d'une droite dure en
campagne en campagne pour l'élection
présidentielle je vais pas leur jeter la
pierre on a fait la même chose en 2011
quand on a pris la majorité sénatoriale
ils sont en campagne mais ça pose aussi
par rapport à ces débats qui ont
commencé cette semaine qu'ils vont se
poursuivre la semaine prochaine on
parlait des institutions le rôle entre
les deux chambres
quel est l'intérêt sincèrement pour nos
compatriotes qui nous regardent de
d'imaginer qu'ils aient eu un temps
législatif à l'assemblée avec des débats
entre la droite et la gauche parfois des
consensus parfois des oppositions ce
texte sort de l'assemblée nationale
arrive au sénat ce fait mais éradiquer
de fond en large pourquoi aussi parce
que en filigrane est assez de
concurrence entre les deux chambres
il va venir à elle existe et donc on va
recommencer deux semaines de débats
antérieurs
on va recommencer deux semaines de
débats tout ça va repartir à l'assemblée
qui aura le dernier mot
on ne dit pas autre chose mais oui mais
il faut passer aux actes maintenant
puisque on a tous le même constat
parce que derrière tout ça le temps de
la fabrique des lois il est longue
d'accord il n'y a pas que ça qui qu'il
faut soigner le fond du fait que au tout
ça
fait fonctionner deux institutions alors
ça coûte aux contribuables aussi un le
fonctionnaire ne m'en fous si comme
certains des courses donc il faut à mon
sens que la chambre qu'elle sénat qui
est du genre exceptionnel et moi je vais
le répéter à mes camarades députés
cette chambre elle est exceptionnelle et
ait une valeur ajoutée au texte et au
contrôle législatif
il faut peut-être que l'on réfléchisse
non pas une fusion avec le cs 2 sachets
ça à des gens qui sont sa économie
sociale à ce que peut-être la chambre
des collectivités puissent être plus
tourné vers les territoires encore plus
emma s'occuper forcément des textes et
pas cher shalit et citoyen a cherché
pour cela les a même été amorcée à
l'époque avec jean pierre bel décide
même l'avènement du cndd mi mai
l'assemblée nationale gérard larcher il
essaie encore une fois de mimer
l'assemblée nationale pourquoi parce
qu'il a mis ses cavalerie derrière lui
en ordre de marche pour aller chercher
la présence de la république pour le
candidat qui sortira de déprimer à se
faire il se sert du sénat c'est ce que
vous dites il se sert du sénat comme
d'un message politique sur le thème vous
voyez ce que nous majorité de droite
sénatoriale
nous pourrions faire toute la droite
rassemblée si demain nous savons pouvoir
il envoie nos compatriotes un message si
le message qu'ils envoient c'est la
suppression de l' entrave à lille et
j'ai par exemple un délit d'entravé
l'idée g6 et le message qu'ils ont voit
c'est que des territoires comme le mien
seront pas et dès demain pour l'aide à
la pierre
construire des logements sociaux si
c'est ça le message qu'ils s'envoient
nos compatriotes qui ne s'inquiète pas
gérard larcher un mois je vais dire ce
qu'ils sont en train de faire et on sera
nombreux à le répéter
vous avez déposé également des
amendements sur les pour augmenter des
peines pour les hauts fonctionnaires
coupable de propos homophobes ou
racistes
est-ce que sexiste homophobe un
antisémite raciste
quelles sont vos chances de voir adopter
c'est à moi j'espère que d'abord ce
n'est pas pour les on pourrait faire
d'autres en sus la rage histoire ça à
faire consensus
on voit bien dans la période que dans
laquelle nous sommes que la parole se
libère quand même près nos concitoyens
mais se libère facilement désormais en
ce sens bien je suis lui de 2
comme une merde elle formule je le vois
bien au quotidien alors face à cette
liberté ton désormais moi je pense que
toutes les personnes qui sont
détentrices de l'autorité publique un
fonctionnaire un militaire un ministre
un parlementaire qu'il est amené à
déraper sur tous ces sujets ces propos
sexistes propos racistes propos
homophobes propos antisémites propos
antimusulmans
eh bien ces personnes là de vraies et
devront à mieux être sanctionné
lourdement
voilà ce que je demande si vos
amendements ne sont pas accepter ça
voudra dire quoi selon vous mais je vais
me battre pour qu'il le soit mais je
n'ai pas sa semaine prochaine donc j'ai
encore quelques jours pour convaincre si
tant est qu'il y en ait quelques
réticents à ouvrir une séquence
politique à présent emmanuel macron
était en meeting à strasbourg et devant
ses partisans dans marches l'ancien
milieu de l'économie à ébaucher un
programme
il s'en est pris à ses rivaux qu'il soit
de gauche mais aussi de droite emmanuel
macron démonstration de force pour
emmanuel macron mille personnes réunies
à strasbourg et des moyens techniques
importants pour mettre en scène le
diagnostic de l'ancien ministre sur
l'état de la france
je pourrais aussi vous faire des
propositions vous donnez tout de suite
les conclusions emmanuel macron refuse
encore de faire des propositions
précises
il préfère dresser le portrait d'une
france malade à réformer en urgence
c'est à peine si le presque candidat
donne quelques pistes sur l'instauration
de la proportionnelle aux élections ou
encore sur le contrôle de l'action du
président de la république par des
citoyens tirés au sort
le temps du programme viendra plus tard
en attendant emmanuel macron préfère
cibler alain juppé et nicolas sarkozy
sur le terrain de l'honnête et personnel
peut-on imaginer sérieusement commander
aux destinées du pays ou même simplement
se présentaient aux suffrages des
français alors que sa probité
personnelle a été mise en cause
c'est pourquoi il faudrait subordonnés
l'accès aux fonctions ministre
yelle et élective à l'absence
d'inscription au casier judiciaire
v2 emmanuel macron et deux passionnés
par ses partisans
mais à la sortie du meeting et l'absence
de propositions concrètes divise le
public
c'est le discours que j'attendais un peu
d un début de propositions un début
d'action un début d'orientation des
jeunes et c'est bon pour le renouveau
mai
mais j'attends encore de voir des choses
des propositions plus concrètes
imperméable aux critiques
emmanuel macron avance étape par étape
il continuera son diagnostic sur l'état
de la france la semaine prochaine la
question de sa candidature elle ne sera
pas abordée avant la fin de l'année
voilà pour ce reportage signé jean
baptiste daoulas le carbonate est-ce que
emmanuel macron qui a quand même une
bonne cote d'après certains sondages est
une menace pour le parti socialiste pour
la gauche même qu'avant le reportage je
reconnais que michael ça mais ça a été
très aimable puisqu'il a parlé de
l'annnonce de son programme
moi j'aime donc toujours de voir le
programme de monsieur bah kron quant à
la menace je sais pas de quelle menace
on me parle parce que je regarde comme
vous les enquêtes de l'opinion bon je
vois qu'il 30 de plus en plus dans
l'électorat de droite
je considère qu'on a un huitième
candidat pour la primaire à droite
macron qui se dit candidat antisystème
je rappelle simplement que son directeur
de campagne et direct la communication
d'un grand groupe du cac 40 que lui même
qui est anti système est financé par un
certain monsieur herman milliardaire qui
robert qui est qui qui financent et qui
l'accompagnent qu'il ya beaucoup de
startups heures millionnaire qui sont
air lui tant mieux pour lui 13 pas bien
ce que si c'est ça la modernité ou
l'anticipent messieurs macron a été
celui qui a tenu la plume de jacques
attali quand il fallait faire les 110
propositions à nicolas sarkozy
ensuite le un magnifique parcours à la
banque rothschild
il est arrivé ensuite aux côtés de
françois hollande est donc à l'elysée du
puy 2012 comme secrétaire geneviève
incarne un système et après par le fait
du prince
il est devenu mini sens jamais de passer
par la case suffrage universel tout en
ayant toute une série catalogue
à la prévert si vous la proposition nous
instituons connais pas m mais il est
seul il peut éventuellement être
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
peut-être douars de la primaire la
question de qualité très clair peut-il
faire perdre la gauche
bah il sera candidat à l'élection
présidentielle moi je verrais ça le 15
mars au plus tard s'il a eu ses
parrainages aux français parce que moi
je veux bien que tout ça soit
communication mais j'aimerais bien aussi
entendre des réel soutien aujourd'hui de
monsieur macron à part les dix
parlementaires qui sont derrière lui
est-ce qui soutient l monsieur macron
moi je veux bien qu'on soit sérieux tout
moi je peux être candidat aussi on peut
toucher le dernier devrait vous pouvez
nous le dira mais je ne le suis pas
rassurez vous en tous les cas pas cette
fois ci en que voulez vous je vous dise
il est le produit du système est la même
un discours à la limite du populisme
on peut juste là a dit manuel valls moi
je dirais populistes ou court et quand
on est soi-même le fruit toussaint
pirette et le pôle l'est vouloir tout
tout me balancer avec l'eau du bain
bon c'est faux un peu avoir sa propre
introspection de ce qu'on aime
vous êtes assez ses frères même très
c'est là qu'elle est non je suis
réaliste
quel est selon vous son plus grand
handicap le fait qu'il n'ait jamais de
mandat qui n'a jamais été élu non c'est
pas un handicap même si sa flûte la
perception c'est quand on est confronté
au quotidien je suis maire mr s'est pas
de 8 heures du matin à 17 heures le soir
c'est sept jours sur céline je vis
évidemment dans ma commune je croise
mais habitant mes concitoyens tous les
jours et si c'est tous les jours vous
êtes confrontés à la réalité du monde
je pense que quand on est sous les ors
de la république pendant trop longtemps
on peut perdre un peu ce lien avec le
terrain suffit pas de faire quelques
immersion des bains de foule ou si je
peux vous organisez des bonnes foules et
dire qu'on est dans une immersion parce
que ça fait de belles images mais la
réalité c'est que je pense que lui
manque que ce vrai vécu d'élu local
janvier peut-être sur une tanière
questions sur concernant emmanuel macron
et concernant les membres du parti
socialiste et parlementaires qui
pourraient le soutenir yona je pense au
maire de lyon gérard collomb et d'autre
que risque-t-il au sein du parti
socialiste
qu'est ce que vous aimeriez qu'il se
passait ce qu'il faut les sanctionner ce
qu'il faut moi je suis écouté j'ai
jamais été pour la chasse aux sorcières
j'entends ça
je suis pour le rassemblement de ma
famille d'abord et puis la suite si
quelques-uns de nos amis gérard collomb
est quand même coutumier d'être un
électron libre
voilà il ya quand même des cas d'espèce
gérard c'est gérard en venir se passera
rien quoi moi je sais pas ce qu'il se
passera la main je suis pas premier
secrétaire du parti je pense que cet
amour et importants du parti des
camarades du dans ces circonscriptions
là j'imagine vous demander des comptes à
leurs députés
vous savez je pense qu'ils font parce
que j'ai regardé les collègues qui
soutiennent macron je pense qu'ils font
une mauvaise analyse de leur
circonscription parce qu'ils ont été
élus sur des circonscriptions qui en
2012 était très à droite et dans la
vague rose
ils ont réussi à emporter au siège je
pense qu'ils croient qu'il théorise que
en étant avec macron ils iront crantée
des voix centre centre-droit vous savez
cette théorie de mettre la gauche au
centre moi ça commence à bien faire pour
moi il faut mettre la gauche à gauche
d'abord et après on se dépasse ces sages
très clair le carreau nas c'est l'heure
d'accueillir notre partenaire du
figaro.fr jim jarrassé qui arrive dans
un instant
j'ai déjà assez c'est à vous pour samy
bonjour carbone à ce jour les en début
d'émission de la réforme
institutionnelle si vous avez des
propositions sur le sujet et notamment
la mise en place d'un vote à point alors
ce serait un système un peu nouveau
c'est à dire que l'électeur disposerait
de quatre points à répartir entre
différents cas d'un candidat
catllar mettons à la configuration de
2017 vos quatre qu'on a voulu carvounas
vous les attribuer à qui françois
hollande est
et ben si ça si françois hollande est
candidat à l'élection présidentielle je
l'aurais même les 4 mai quatre points et
le bonus sb moi je suis légitime ici je
le souvenir du candidat d'accord est ce
que vous seriez prêt à signer l'appel à
la candidature de françois hollande qui
a été diffusé cette semaine par un un
cadre du parti socialiste celui là n'ont
par contre si l'initiative au niveau du
groupe au sénat et que didier guillaume
me le propose sont le fait de le signer
j'ai appris ça pour le moment je ne suis
pas au courant de cet appel donc on
n'est pas venu vers moi mais
naturellement dont jeu j'en appelle à ce
trio qui n'hésite pas à m'appeler parce
que je signerai l'appel dès demain donc
vous faites partie des soutiens actifs
de françois hollande mais encore heureux
ouais il y en a encore beaucoup vous
savez il y en a encore beaucoup et on va
faire la campagne vous savez on nous
donne perdants mais on nous donnait
perdant 81 d'acheter du sein voilà vous
avez raison ça c'est la démocratie
sondagière et vous savez le peuple
français c'est un peu extrêmement
politique et les français sous la vème
république quand on regarde l'ordre
d'arrivée du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle pas de chance n'est
jamais ce que les sondages ont annoncé
et donc ne nous donnait pas enfin pas
vous mais nous nous donnons pas l'idée
que nous allons
être battu avant même d'avoir fait la
campagne ce qui est bien entouré
françois hollande on se souvient vous
étiez à ses critiques sur le dispositif
et au la gauche ans et ses ministres qui
le soutenait lors de grands meetings
là il a mis en place un son entourage a
mis en place une cellule riposte qui a
pour but de créer des argumentaires pour
contrer un peu la droite mais est ce que
ça fait un programme de dire avec juppé
ou avec sarkozy ce sera pire qu'avec moi
c'est une bonne stratégie
en tous les cas je crois qu'il faut
maintenant qu'on explique à nos
compatriotes même à nos compatriotes qui
ont le coeur à gauche qui seraient
tentés parce que dans une telle
désespérance de croire justement que
nous allons perdre les élections qu'il
vaut mieux avoir le moins pire à savoir
alain juppé demain président de la
république alain juppé nicolas sarkozy
c'est bonnet blanc et blanc bonnet
j'entendais monsieur macron qui disait
le rapport à la justice avec nicolas
sarkozy
et paf les alain juppé a été condamné
par la justice il a été condamné
alain juppé qui vient nous voir nous les
français vous et moi qui va nous
expliquer qu'on voit prendre vous et moi
la retraite à 65 ans alain juppé l'a
pris sa retraite à 57 ans donc là c'est
faites ce que je dis pas cela je pense
c'est une bonne chose c'est à dire dire
la droite mais non avec pierre la
riposte
moi je suis dans la riposte permanente
c'est de dire à nos concitoyens demain
la droite ces trois cent mille emplois
de moins dans le service public ça va
être pris ou dans la police à l'école où
c'est ça les vraies questions
regardez en parlait la loi l'égalité
citoyenne blé mais regardez ce que la
droite sénatoriale a fait dans les
coupes sombres parlera pas en compte vos
délits d' entrave sur l'idée g par
rapport aux questions de logement par
rapport aux questions des minima sociaux
mais que les gens se réveillent ils se
rendent compte de ces macro emmanuel
macron quand il parle de nicolas sarkozy
du nord il ne doit pas se présenter aux
yeux des français devant les français
vous dit la même chose pour alain juppé
si je comprends bien
non chacun a conscience mais ceux qui
choisissent le peuple français il ya
juste une classe il s'appelle l'élection
et donc il faut juste que chacun nos
compatriotes se disent si demain pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de la vème
république
on envoie à l'elysée un homme qui a été
condamné par la justice française c'est
ça la vraie question est ce que c'est
comme cela on parlait de nos
institutions qu'on veut les voir se
développer
on veut des x des situations à la
balkany condamné un jour réussi un autre
jour moi c'est pas ma tasse de thé
mission que
koné sarkozy voilà juppé pour dommages
en sont les points là pour moi quand on
est condamné par la justice
on ne peut plus représenter une élection
donc on l'a compris donc hollande se
prépare vous le soutenez mais il ya
toujours le cas de la défaillance qui
étiez possible n'y croyais pas j'étais
désolé c'est possible on sait qu'elle a
dans ce cas là manuel valls dirait il se
prépare alors ça cette question-là aimé
poser à chaque fois je souris parce qu'à
un moment on m'a quand j'étais jeune on
les bases et en retire donc quand
j'étais jeune en 10 heures en
communication pour qu'un message soit
reçu il faut le répéter au moins treize
fois il ya des lagides manger
aujourd'hui à masséna ya des signes
gabonais estime que manuel valls fait
toujours un passage qu'il est sous la
terreur son passage au grand jury
dimanche dernier où il s'est mis dans la
peau du président de la république
la veille il avait rassemblé ses
soutiens à matignon vous y étiez bien
sûr qu'est ce que ça veut dire tout ça
les bas ça veut dire que cet homme qui a
concouru en 2011 à la première primaire
citoyenne organisée en france c'est nous
la gauche qu'il avions inventé j'ai été
son directeur de campagne donc manuel
valls moi je n'ai pas changé danalyse je
le voyais en 2011
candidat à la présidence de la
république aujourd'hui je le vois
république pour les prières de 2021
n'imaginez pas un seul instant un os ou
le jean orial ou sous le poids de la
vème république un président sortant n'a
y pas à la compétition pour la première
raison qui est la suivante c'est que
c'est sa responsabilité
moi ça fait cinq ans que je me bats avec
d'autres un dans ma ville au parlement
pour défendre le bilan
la première responsabilité de françois
hollande qui est un homme d'état qui ne
fuira pas ses responsabilités ses dents
et la gauche à la compétition et donc
toucheront derrière lui et que se
passe-t-il si françois hollande perd la
primaire à gauche vous allez soutenir
arnaud montebourg si françois hollande
berland par souci françois hollande perd
la primaire je pense que la campagne
présidentielle évidemment nous serons
tous derrière le
vainqueur de là on les rend à la honte
heureusement sais pas quoi je pensais je
pensais pas que j'étais dans une
émission littéraire ou de science
fiction on est tous là plein de sujets
non mais soyons sérieux et en même temps
les électeurs de gauche sont
légitimistes par contre ma crainte pour
être tout à fait honnête c'est que
françois hollande ne gagne pas bien
j'imagine pas demain dans la primaire
françois hollande qui gagne à 53 54
il faut qu'ils gagnent bien et pour bien
gagner il faut se mobiliser et faire la
campagne sur le bilan sur projet sur la
famille du défunt l'inflation pour
revenir sur manuel valls on a
l'impression vous êtes un peu éloigné de
certaines de ses prises de position
notamment sur le thème de la laïcité de
l'identité on vous a entendu notamment
sur le sujet du burkini cette année
prendre un peu vos distances avec le
premier ministre
qu'est ce que ça veut dire est-ce que je
sourirai c'est pas pour me moquer en
attendant mais est ce que il ya dix ans
par son fils mais entre vous sur ce
sujet je vais vous dire je suis l'ami de
baduel valls qu'est ce qu'on attend d'un
ami et encore plus quand on est un homme
d'état comme manuel valls et qu'il vous
dise la vérité
est ce que dans ce que je viens
d'évoquer dans la vision que j'ai de cet
homme que je vois un jour président la
république qu'est ce que vous croyez que
ses amis proches servirait cette
ambition collective pour la france si
nous étions amenés à ne pas dire nous
mêmes la vérité sont quoi nous pensons
s'y faire cela c'est d'être opposé à la
personne que je soutiens on n'a pas tout
à fait la même analyse de la fidélité
manuel valls a toujours dit je suis un
premier ministre de françois hollande et
libre je suis l'ami le fidèle de manuel
valls ellisdon n'a pas l'air si vous
montrez le mot de la fin
merci d'avoir été l'invité de cette
émission on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine bonne semaine à tous